YONDU UDONTA
Why stop at one hero...
...when we can
show you all of them.
♪♪
THE WATCHER
Heroes are forged in darkness,
defined by sacrifice.
There is still hope
for the Multiverse.
♪♪
STEPHEN STRANGE
Here we go.
T'CHALLA
We do not back down from a fight.
THANOS
Aye aye, commander.
CLINT BARTON
Now or never.
THOR
Zombies, great idea!
NICK FURY
That doesn't sound ominous at all.
SCOTT LANG
Hey!
PEGGY CARTER
Who needs a plan?
I have a shield.
♪♪
HULK
[Growls]
STEPHEN STRANGE
What happened to you?
CORRUPTED STRANGE
You will see.
♪♪
THE WATCHER
Witness the biggest heroes
of the Multiverse.
HOWARD THE DUCK
Or small, if you catch my drift.
♪♪
HOWARD THE DUCK
You know what they say,
when you're out of luck,
always go duck.
T'CHALLA
I'm pretty sure no one says that.